uh welcome to buy a data gender webinar
uh
i'm sadie and here with me
and from behind the scenes
of the team uh this is our fourth
webinar and we are getting better and
doing this
so yay um today we have
um a special speaker actually a
colleague from another pi data chapter
he is the co-chair of by data mr dam
and he will talk about beijing her call
time
series analysis with prophet and by mca
3.
so um mathias the mic is yours
right awesome thanks um can i
yeah i'll share my screen as well
right so you should be able to see my
slides now right
yes cool awesome right
yes so um thanks for that introduction
indeed my name is uh
my name is matthias i am indeed the data
science lead at
whoops it's a bit slow
yeah i'm indeed the data scientist
accelerated um
and at work i've been responsible for
training educating
and developing over 50 junior media data
scientists
in all kinds of different topics um
and actually the stuff that i'm about to
present to you today
is also something that sort of came out
of this training and out of some of the
work i've seen these these accelerators
uh
do at clients and me thinking that there
had to be a better way to solve their
issues
um as you said i'm also indeed actively
involved in in
two other chapters of pi data both the
pi data
amsterdam conference and meetup as well
as the pi data global virtual conference
um from this year november 11th
till 15th apart from that i like to do
open source stuff so i i maintain a
project called scikit lego which is a
library that just contains
like things that we found to be useful
over the years when building psychic
learn models
and i recently started this this time
series thing
um about paradiddle global i do want to
plug the event a bit
uh tickets are on sale at the moment and
the program is announced
tickets are pay what you want so it's
accessible to
uh to as many people as possible
um we have like more than 70 talks i
think and like a dozen tutorials a bunch
of short talks
and some extra curricular so it should
be a lot of fun
but that's not what we're going to be
talking about here today
um today i would like to discuss with
you a specific type of time series
problem
and a namely a a business time series
forecasting problem
because forecasting is one of those
things that you just happen to do as
data scientists in a lot of
organizations
because it's very often sort of the most
common
input to all kinds of planning and
scheduling
problems right stuff like workforce
planning but also capacity planning and
maybe
factory expansion decisions or assembly
line changeovers that need to happen and
while it's therefore very important
time series modeling can be also very
tricky especially in these
in these business contexts because
generally your data
like it's not super good so what i have
here
is uh it's not real data it's fictitious
data but it resembles
sort of the um the patterns that you
would generally see
in some kind of um like
fast moving consumer goods or whatever
type
um manufacturing process we have a bunch
of pro
products that are tracked over over a
certain amount of time
in this case the longest time span is
about two years from the start of 2018
till about now and um all these
all these time series they have some
things in common
right what we see is we see some obvious
yearly seasonality where we have a
repeating cycle over a year where
um sometimes products sell more
sometimes products sell less
but there also seems to be some kind of
weekly seasonality going on
um there seems to be missing data right
all these
these weird little spikes down to zero
are probably indicative of measurement
errors or just data not not being
collected properly
um but there's also trend changes
especially
like near the start of 2020 in the blue
line we see there's an obvious trend
change
we have newly introduced products the
gray the
green the yellow ones are definitely
starting later on in our time series and
some of them are even stopping early and
then there's these
these yellow and these orange and these
blue bands sort of
around here that have some kind of
promotional activity or some kind of
non-seasonal event that um increased the
sales during an amount of time
and i plotted five here but in most
contexts you would actually
not have just five of these you would
have like
for each product for each sku of that
product for each region that you're
selling you kind of want to fit these
time series
so very often it's it's more in the
order of hundreds than tents
and if you try to to model this with
classical time series models where you
sort of try to
get that generative process that made
your data
um then you're going to struggle because
you would end up with some kind of
maybe it's a remax model because there's
the seasonality you need to capture and
then there's these ultra regressive
components
um but generally those seasonalities
aren't
meant to go back an entire year
because basically what what it does from
how those models learn is they look at
what was the future value
one period of seasonality go and they
try to learn a ways like
how much should this weigh in the
prediction that i'm gonna make for
tomorrow
but especially for these newer products
for like orange and
or sorry yellow and green these ones at
the end here
there's no way we can look back an
entire year
and like there's there's a bunch of
these kinds of issues
also generally you can't really model
multiple seasonalities in one go or at
least not natively you would have to use
some kind of 3a decomposition
um all these like these additional
promotion effects are kind of hard to
model missing data you would need to
impute
the very least or somehow remove but you
need to deal with it
and that just doesn't scale
when it comes to the amount of effort
that you need to do for all these
hundred time series
to actually be able to model them
um and that's actually exactly the
problem what
that that some researchers at facebook
at some point also faced
they have a very similar situation where
they have like probably
tens of thousands time to they actually
want to model but not
the the people capacity with the time
series experience to actually properly
model all of those
so that's why they decided to tackle
this some other way they came up with
this thing called
profit and
what is profit um then so profit
kind of tries to do away with that
entire let's model the
degenerative process of our data and
instead it tries to say
well how about we just treat it as a
curve fitting exercise
where we have a bunch of different
components
and those components can be summed
together just
just sum them together to in the end
produce
the time series that you that you want
to fit
and on the screen here we see we see two
main components
a trend and a seasonal component and
then there's
a bunch of additional regressors that
you could add that could take any
real shape or form that you that you
want it assumes the noise is then
independently distributed around these
predictions
because most of the trend and all the
other things should be captured in one
of those
components and the nice thing about this
is that it in theory is a really
flexible way to fit time series
because if you want a slightly different
way
that seasonality should work according
to what you
think your problem domain calls for
then you should be able to say let's
grab this seasonality component
take it out and think of a slightly
different way
to add that to our final predictions
um and also that entire problem that we
had with missing data is not really
relevant anymore
because you don't do an ultra-regressive
model but you do curve fitting
you simply don't look at the
measurements that are missing don't
really need to deal with those anymore
um also the decomposition thing just
makes it really nice to
go back and see like okay why did a
certain prediction come to be here like
what is my model actually learning
because you can look at the trend
individually from the seasonality and
from any other
um any other additional regressors
there's some parts of a profit that i
that i don't think are sufficient for
for for this problem that i'm describing
to you here
um the first one is basically that
profit
well that that flexibility that the get
that this
decomposition model sort of promises
isn't really realized in the way
that profit is set up um it's not very
easy for
someone randomly to go in and change one
component while keeping the rest without
needing to sort of
change the entire source code of the
thing and also
if we look carefully at this data um
you might say that there isn't five
individual seasonalities in this series
it could very well be that there's
actually only one seasonal effect
but some of the products are co-seasonal
and some of the products are contrast
season
right so we would kind of want to to be
able to model that effect and be able to
tell our model like
these time series should share some of
their parameters maybe
and unfortunately the way that profit is
set up that's just not possible
so what i set out to do was basically to
think of a way into open source a way in
which we could
model these series in a more playful
interactive way while keeping into
account these
shared parameter spaces and to do that
we have to first look at okay what does
profit actually do
when it fits a trend and when it fits
the seasonality
and it turns out that those are actually
relatively straightforward
um the paper suggests two ways of
dealing with the
with the trend one is a linear trend and
one is a
saturating growth for the problems that
i've been facing the linear
trend um seems to perform better
and seems to make more sense so that's
also the thing that i implemented up
until now
um and how it works is that basically
you take a starting initial
growth how much does our trend increase
for each
time step and that's this variable k
here
and in order to say that it should be a
possible for this trend to change over
time
what the profit model does is it
introduces
regularly spaced change points and
by default these are just like regularly
spaced in
your domain if you have some domain
knowledge you could also tell it to
basically put these change points at
specific moments where
you know something has changed um but
the general justice just make sure that
there's enough of them
and put a strongly regularizing prior on
it
to sort of shrink it down to zero for
the cases where nothing really is
expected to change and the growth at a
certain point in time is then basically
this this summation
so the growth or the trend at a certain
time is the initial growth
plus all the the sum of all the deltas
that have
already passed
this sum is not super great to model
though right if you need to write this
down
in a matrix way then this summation can
be can be tedious
so the paper actually models it slightly
different
um all this math by the way is directly
from the paper it's
quite accessible and readable if you if
you are interested in it or if you want
to learn more
i highly recommend to to give it a read
um but basically rather than doing the
summation
uh the profit paper suggests to fit this
big indicator matrix a
and this is a matrix of size time steps
by size change points
and it basically has a one for each
change point that have or
has already occurred at a certain time
so it's just a big matrix of zeros and
ones
and to model then the trend point
at a certain time you can basically take
the initial growth
and multiply this matrix a this
indicator matrix
with the learned matrix delta so
this matrix delta with the change points
is the thing that we're actually going
to try and
fit and we multiply that with time
and if we just take this left part then
that doesn't give a continuous trend
because there's step changes in these
growth changes
so in order to then make it continuous
again they introduce this offset term
it's like an initial intercept this is
also a learnable parameter this
m and a half plus a times
minus sd to basically offset the change
that the stem function is going to make
so what i would now like to do if i can
find the new share button
um to sort of
give a better idea of like what what
this does
um
is show you this um
this streamlit the small little
streamlit app that i made
so here we see basically the same
formulation that we had on the slides
for the entire model and also for the
linear trend
and what we have on the left side here
in this sidebar
are the learnable parameters of this
profit model
and so these are our different deltas
this initial
growth and this this interceptor
and it turns out that if you want to
write this down in a bit of numpy then
it's actually
quite simple to do the inference part of
this
model and what we see is that if we
change our initial growth
then sort of our growth is constant for
the entire duration but it's non-zero
which means our trend increases over
time
this m our intercept we can move it down
a bit and then we see
the entire trend just move downwards and
if we want to have an ever increasing
growth we can basically
put all of these individual deltas at
one so we see the growth
at each change point making a small step
and offsets making uh every increasingly
bigger step to sort of counteract this
this step function to make a nice smooth
little trend
right so these are learnable parameters
and the way that profit then suggests to
learn these
is in the bayesian framework so profit
is written
in stan stand is a probabilistic
programming language
that allows you to basically write down
uh i have some prior belief over my
parameters i have some observed data
this is how my pro my my parameters
relate to the observed data
please sample posterior distributions
for my parameters so we get sort of
fitted distributions of what our
parameters
could look like and well so profit is
written in in stan
i don't really know stan all that well
so i decided
let's go and rewrite this in pimc3
so what i'm going to do now is basically
load our data and see how we could write
up this
this linear trend part in straight up
times code so let's start with
loading our data and i think i call it
time series series.csv
yep and i'm gonna start with
just taking um
the summer one product right i just
wanna
fit one product at a time for now just
to keep it simple
um what i'm going to do next is i'm
going to take the the value column
and i'm going to uh
min max scale it to make sure that it's
nicely
between zero and one and i'm gonna take
the time column and i'm gonna make it a
daytime just to assure that it is and
then
our data will look something like this
yeah so we have
um basically some some data over time
with with their corresponding values
and then the next thing that we need to
do is set up some some hyperparameters
for a model so this change points is a
hyperparameter
um i kind of want to have a
an array
of times that's also min max skills also
between zero and one
and then i can basically use both of
these things together
to
make our change points evenly
distributed
over our entire domain using these two i
can
come up with this this indicator matrix
so this
i kind of want this to be a 2d matrix of
size t by
s so i'm gonna first append
like a just a single dimensional entry
to it to make the t
data frame or the t matrix
two-dimensional
and whenever it's bigger than s i'm
gonna get a true and a false
i'm gonna multiply it by one
to have a nice integer indicating your
array right so we haven't really done
any fitting yet but this is just all the
setup that we that we need to do
um now to actually go and
fit these parameters in pi and c3 we we
need to work in one of these
pm.model context managers and what we're
going to do in here is basically
define all the priors and tell pimc how
they relate
so we can in the in the end call
pm.sample
to to kick off this process called
markov chain monte carlo
to to figure out what the posterior
distributions for our parameters
basically look like
i kind of like starting these models at
the bottom so
um and at the bottom we start with okay
what is our observed data actually
and we had we basically already said
that our noise was assumed to be
iid so what we can say is that we're
gonna have
uh normally distributed data it's called
observations or something
that is distributed around the trend
that we're gonna try and
predict with some kind of error
that we also don't know yet so that's
also something we're going to fit
but we have observed this data and so
we're going to say we're observing the
df
these these value columns from our data
frame and they should be around this
trend with a certain standard deviation
now we can basically go go up a bit
and define how these parameters should
be
like where these parameters actually
come from like where does this trend
come from and where does this error come
from
well we don't know the error and
whenever we don't know something
in pi mc we simply make a parameter out
of it and we
put a prior on it and in this case i'm
saying
the error term is drawn from a half
cauchy prior
which is basically a normal distribution
but with fatter tails
and then only the positive part because
a standard deviation cannot be deposited
and that's it for our error in the trend
we can basically just
um write down the formula that we had
also in the streamlit app
it's the k plus the dot product between
a and delta
times t plus
this initial offset plus the
yeah plus the dot product between a and
minus s times delta
right that's exactly the formulation
that we have and now we're left with a
couple of things we need to define okay
what is k
what is m and what is delta
so k was our initial growth and because
everything is
is standard skill we can basically say
well i'm not sure yet what it is it can
be positive it can be negative
so let's just draw it from a normal
distribution
centered around zero like a standard
normal distribution
and something similar that something
we'll do for this this offset
but i'm really not sure how like where
it starts so let's make this a
wider normal distribution
and in this delta thing we said we
wanted to
regular rise heaven so what we'll do is
we'll put a
laplacian prior on it and the laplacian
is sort of like this very
steeply peaked distribution this is very
much
weight around zero and that has the
effect that parameters will get drawn to
to the zero value and basically make it
make it zero
um uh if you use lasso in linear
regression mass of regularization
that's that's actually sort of the same
thing bayesian regression
with a laplace prior is sort of l1
regularization
regular linear regression model
and these deltas can be much smaller
because we we kind of say well we don't
expect our trend to change all that much
so
put a rather narrow prior on it
and we also will give it a shape
because this delta wasn't just one value
it was it was a vector and so we can
tell it
we can have imc please fit
in this case 10 independent uh
laplacians on it
and the step that we need to do to
actually sort of fit this model is
called this piano sample thing
and pianville sample will kick off this
process called microchime monte carlo
specifically
with a
with an algorithm called nuts no uterine
sampler
it's sort of this more advanced way of
doing
the regular metropolis hastings it uses
that's also why
pimc depends on fianna and that's why i
use the fianno
dot product here because it uses this
gradient information to basically say
okay how
where should i go and explore this this
space
and what you're gonna do is well
when this is done fitting we can ask for
what is the the trace plot
and that will show us okay how did pimc
explore our parameter space and what are
sort of
reasonable estimates for
these different parameters
and while this is fitting i'll also just
write out
this which is
some utility functions that i've built
on the sides for
plotting so i need to um
basically put in the the trace mean
trace delta
uh sorry the trace delta
the np dot mean of trace k
and the npl mean of trace
m and i think right
yeah i also needed the s and i had this
other thing called
trend that needed i think the df
yeah the trend df
right so let's look at this thing first
so we asked ymc to go and sample this
it's we'll just actually
this true make it slightly nicer to read
and we basically see that these are then
so
these are the distributions over the
parameters that pi and c think makes
sense
given our model and our observed data so
it thinks the initial growth is sort of
around
one the initial offset is about a half
and then there's a bunch of deltas
ranging between minus four and four the
error is actually quite low
and when we then plot how this
relates to the actual data then we see
that this is the growth that it thinks
makes sense over time this is the offset
that it that corresponds to it
and then this is the fitted model
and funnily enough that this actually
makes
some sense um it's definitely not the
behavior that we want because what
what our model is doing here is using
the change points in the trends
to fit a seasonal pattern and this is
not something that we can extrapolate
but
i mean it clearly shows that it's able
to sort of
adjust to our data and fit accordingly
so this is quite nice um we have a
linear trend
so the next step is going to be our
seasonality and then i'm gonna
swap back to my slides right so
this we've covered this recovery covered
right fourier seasonality
so how profit fits the seasonal
component of your time series
is um basically by fitting a series of
cosines and sines
with different treatment frequencies on
your data
and that is called a fourier series
and basically it's it's shown that any
arbitrary function
if you have an infinite amount of
cosines and sines you can approximate
any different
function and this has one major
hyperparameter
well two actually sorry two major hyper
parameters
um this p which is the periods that you
expect your seasonality to be
and this n which is the number of
components of these
cosines and sines that you're going to
sum together
so this n this end basically um
is in the i always forget it's the
denominator no the numerator
of this of this fraction so if n
increases the frequency of your cosine
and sine waves
also increases and these a of n and this
b of n are then the fitted parameters so
we have two times
n two times big and number of fitted
parameters for this
model and what it then looks like
is basically like this so this is
some learned weight times our initial
cosine
some other weight times our initial sine
wave and those two get sumped together
then we have a higher frequency wave
coming through it
added up to it and another higher
frequency sine wave added to it
to finally end up with this
major seasonal component
right um that doesn't look so bad so
let's also try to put this thing in
um yeah this one right yes
so you should see streamlit now again
let's
let's see how this works so we have
different whoops
all right there we go we have three
components here so
a0 to a2 and b0 to b2
and we can basically add them together
in a bunch of different ways to come up
with
interesting seasonalities
right i i don't think this one will
actually make a lot of sense in most use
cases but
who knows right
so all these different ways are summed
together
it gets added with our trend to get to a
final
prediction for our for our series
so let's try to build this in um
in pi mc as well i'm just going to go
back here
and add these additional hyper
parameters that we need
let's start with the number of
components that's this order of the
fourier series that we needed
and then we need some kind of function
um that basically makes this the values
for the fourier series
the unweighted values for the 48 series
i'm going to say this is a this is this
function x
it takes t it takes the periods and it
takes the
uh the order and then small x is two
times np double pi
times np dot a range of n i think i'll
need brackets on this
plus one right this is the the numerator
question from robert uh he's asking uh
can each change point have its own prior
parameter
or price distribution ah that's a good
question
um so in profit no
the default uh allows you to only set
a single prior but there's nothing
really stopping you from doing that
differently
um if you have a good reason to say
like it's actually not a bad idea right
because you sort of expected in the
beginning of
launching a new product the trend might
change more heavily than
sort of when it's established so yeah
makes sense
um it's not something i thought about
for time series yet so currently it's
not possible but it should be relatively
straightforward to add so
thanks for that suggestion
is there another question or oh not yet
i'm losing my zoom bar ah that's it cool
right um where was it yeah so this um
this x of t then the final thing that's
left is
once again do this uh this broadcasting
trick
for t and divide by the periodicity and
we concatenate these together
the cosine version of it and the sine
version of it
over x is one
so this x of t basically gives us
a big array of these uh six fourier
components for all time steps
so that's something that we can use
inside our model
and then actually the main thing that we
need to
change as well rather than saying that
we observe our trend data is that we
observe our predictions
and our predictions are our trend plus
our seasonality
and our seasonality is this x of t
um multiplied with beta so it's the dot
product of this
and beta and beta is then
once again a learned parameter so once
again we put a prior on it
zero one and it's a vector so it's the
n components times two
because cosine and sine get their own
weights
and if we now fit this then we can look
at the trace
when it's done we can look at the trends
data frame when it's done
and i did something similar similar
for the seasonal prediction so let's
start building that part already it's
the seasonal components
it's time and then probably the
trace beta
once again over x is zero and then
plots c is no components
e f and c is no df
and that's done i should be is here
let's say
all um df trendy f
so we see that fitting is not super fast
um the sampling process in
microchip multi-color is generally not
as fast as doing just
uh just optimization because it also
gives us a different
answer rather than just saying i think
this is the highest likelihood point
it says this is a distribution of likely
values
and just inherently that's a more costly
computation to do
but it also gives us something powerful
which is
forecasting uncertainty and
there's something that went wrong here
right i need to divide this um this x of
t
this needs to be 365.25
if divided by the length of t because
this t
is scaled
that's going to make more sense um but
it gives us
un forecasting uncertainty and if you're
going to make
decisions uh to maybe expand your
factory or to do workforce planning
you kind of want to have different
scenarios like what is the likelihood
that this will actually happen and
what's the range on possible values that
it can take so this and
this this forecasting uncertainty is is
very powerful in that sense
right so this is the fitted version of
our second model that makes a lot more
sense
we see the trend indeed increases over
time so our
just our trend prediction is kind of
gibberish when we compare it to the
results
and the same thing happens when we just
look at the seasonal part
of our decomposition but actually when
you add them together
it suddenly makes a lot of sense again
um
and we actually are able to fit our mall
relatively
relatively well we definitely didn't
capture
any kind of weekly seasonality because
that's not something that we described
in our model yet um but you could see
that probably
like taking these two things and adding
um a single other parameter vector
beta um and specifying the seasonality
differently
you can add the the weekly seasonality
effect
rather straightforward
let's go back to slides first
yeah so this is done
right so but before we actually go in
and
do that um
it's worth a bit about discussing like
how are we gonna formalize this
because it's nice that we were able to
sort of write down these components and
then we would
be able to write them in pimc
but not everyone knows pimc and
needing to write these things from
scratch every time for each specific
model that you want
kind of takes away the speed of
iteration that you
that you generally look for when you
want to model these kinds of problems
so let's draw some inspiration
from two other packages obviously profit
but also the the forecast package in r
so what profit does is use in
a fluent api and a fluent api basically
means that
whenever we call a method on an object
then it returns itself so that we can
chain
these objects together so we can start
with a profit model
add a monthly seasonality and add a
yearly seasonality
and that works relatively fine
as long as you're happy with what is in
profit
but we already saw that that we weren't
in
that we might want to add different
types of seasonalities we might want to
add
different ways of combining them right
we could say
this is the seasonality but i want to
multiply it with a constant one or minus
one to sort of indicate this
this co and contrast seasonality and if
i wanted to make those changes
to profit itself i would have to go into
their source code and probably
just rebuild the entire thing and that's
not what i wanted
um so the other option would be to do
basically what what
forecast does in r and that is rely on
this this formula syntax or
in python we have these patch c strings
to specify
different models with different
relationships
um and that's already much more what i'm
looking for because you could imagine
here
we can say well i want to have the trend
plus decisionality
but it could in the very same way say i
want to have the trend
times a seasonality to get a
multiplicative effect
or i want the trend plus open bracket
indicator times seasonality close
bracket
and that's already much more what i what
i want
except that this relies heavily on
non-standard evaluation in r
and that's just something that we don't
have in python
and i also don't want to have some kind
of custom build
string parser for this because then it's
once again very hard to extend to
different classes
my aim with time series is that everyone
can go in
and write a custom component without
needing to touch
the core timesphere codebase
so the solution i came up with um
was to use an expression tree basically
everything in the tree is a note and
every node in and of itself
is a time series model so a linear trend
is a time series model a fourier
seasonality is a time series model
but this multiplication here is also a
time series model
namely a multiplicative time series
and this addition here is an additive
time series model
and these have left and right components
and can sort of recursively go down in
the tree to get the things out that i
that i want to get out from them
so let's start with this sort of small
numerical example just to drive the
point home
like what do i actually mean and how
would this look like in python
i have this class called node here and
has two methods done they're added on
their mall
and for those of you who don't know
these correspond to
the plus operator and the times operator
when we write regular python code
so dunder adds takes two things self and
other the left and the right part
and it returns an add node with the left
part
set to self and the right part set to
other
the same thing goes for the
multiplication node it also has the left
and a right part and the only thing
that's actually
different between the two that is that
when we ask for their values
that the add node takes the left value
plus the right value
and the mall node takes the left value
times the right value
also the string representations are
slightly different but that's
that's just synthetic that's just for us
to look at
we also have this one number class which
is also an instance of note
and it just takes it just represents a
number and its value
is simply s dot n the value that i was
initialized with
and what we can now do is we can define
a computation which is number five six
plus seven times the number eight and
because operator precedence
in python just takes the regular math
operator precedence
it will first multiply 7 and 8 and then
add 5 and 6 to it
to get to the number 67
but what i now also can do is i can
apply brackets
in arbitrary places so you can say well
first please add the numbers five six
and seven together
and then multiply it with the number
eight
and with some imagination
you can probably already see where i'm
going with this
because i can now relatively
straightforwardly
start writing on a class-based approach
to solve this
same problem i can write a
time series model class which is
basically
the the note in the example that we saw
before
and this is therefore where this ads
will live
self other and it's going to return an
additive
time series object with self and other
as its components and the mole method
of self and other is going to return a
multiplicative
multiplicative time series
object of self and other
and then the other thing that we kind of
need on this is a fifth method
and that takes itself the time and
the values that we want to fit for and
in this fit method i'm gonna
make a primacy model and i'm gonna
recursively
ask myself um what my model definition
is
i'm gonna pass the model the c and the y
in here
and i'm basically going to say that this
is my prediction
and when i have that i can basically go
into this this context manager
once again say oh my my error is from a
half cauchy distribution
with parameter 0.5 and my observed data
is normally distributed
run my prediction my meal is prediction
my sigma is error
and i have observed data
which is why
and we just do pm.sample
so that would be pm.sample i think i had
like tunis 200 draws is
200 courses for
changes for and we store that on cell
cultures
right so this is basically all that's
there for our time series
then we need to write our multiplicative
time series
which is a time series model
which inherits from it and it has an
init method
self left and right self.left is file
self.right r
and the definition of this thing so this
takes cell
model t and y is basically the left
definition
model e and y
times the right
definition of model t and y
and i can do the same thing for an
additive time series but then with a
plus sign
in the middle
the actual components we still also need
to add so we have this linear
oh i should make this classes not
functions
very wrong
um so the linear trend is also a time
series model
and in its init it can basically take
all the hyper parameters that are
relevant for the linear trend
which is the number of change points
it also needs to have a definition of
model tm1
and for this definition we can basically
copy
a bunch of this stuff
so the k the m and the delta and how we
compute the trend
this all needs to happen inside this
model context
and the trend needs to be returned at
the end
and then what we're missing is still
this a and this
s so let's also
copy those
um this needs to be self-doubt and
change points and then that's
i think it is this also needs to be self
within change
someone notices in a typo somewhere
please
please let me know because looking for
them can be
extremely tough when lifeguarding like
this
in the same vein i'm going to make a
fourier seasonality component
so it's also a time series model it also
has a dunder in it
and it takes the p in the end so this is
the period in the
order i'm gonna store those
here as well then
i had this
right i need this x
thing in here
and i need this bit
right i think that's it so
inside this create seasonality i can
also make a depth
definition self model
emy
and open our model context manager
make this put in this beta we have
self.n components
and we'll use self.x of t
and beta um
right this can be subtle p
and we need to return the seasonality at
the end of this
no syntax errors that's always a good
start because what we can now do is say
well give me a model that's a linear
trend
with 10 change points and add a fourier
seasonality
to this
seasonality to this with n equals 3
and p equals
[Music]
did i save the trend on itself nice
volatile fit on the uh on t
and the value
right i'm doing something wrong
missing a
oh right this needs to be selfless model
and then three a seasonality has no this
is just n
and then it says it's not subscriptable
fourier seasonality object is not
subscriptable
right what do i have
right ah this needs self
and then we see another nicely sampling
bit of code
let's take our plotting code from up
here
see if it produces the same results
but rather than putting the trace i'll
put in the modal trace
right exactly the same that's a that's a
good sign
so basically we've changed
this um
this version of our code where we just
have everything written in this
in this one step and we turn it into a
nice bit of object oriented code
that's both open for extension right
because
i can basically everything i need to do
to make a new component is write a class
with a with a definition in there
but it's also closed for modification
because if i want to add a different
component
i once again only have to create a class
and i can directly use it i don't need
to register it somewhere
it doesn't need to be part of some kind
of parser or some kind of other grammar
or method chain
i can just straight away start using it
as long as i have this definition
and this is why i think that this way of
writing down an api for this
is much more powerful because well as i
said you can basically just replace the
plus point
by times and we would get we'll get a
horrendous prediction because this is
obviously not a
multiplicative seasonality problem but
it does just sample and it does just
work without any real
issues
so let's go back to the slides because
i'm not gonna
bore you with waiting for the results
because actually fitting this for five
models does take a bit of time
but the result is this
so we see well we see some things that
we expect and we see some things that
are
horrendously wrong
so our our red product it was indeed
decreasing over time
there's a quite clear seasonal component
to it
um that's very much shared with the blue
line the blue line indeed has a trend
that starts to break around here and
goes up quite a bit
but especially these these new products
the the yellow and the green one
are doing something completely out of
whack
um and that makes sense and also if we
look at the individual components we can
see why it does that
um because there's just a lot of
flexibility in
especially the the seasonal part of the
model
and because there's not a lot of data
it's just going to try and fit as best
as it can and it's not really
constrained by
by other parts of the of the history
so you could now say well let's give up
we can't really make proper predictions
for this
um but we can also say that well
our model is is a bit sick our model has
amnesia
because it's now forgetting
everything that it learned from one
series when it goes to predict the next
one
and that's not a good way to learn about
the world
we have some domain knowledge that says
these should be related they should
share parameters
and the bayesian way of thinking offers
a really nice approach for this
and this concept is called partial
pulling let's imagine for example that
we have
two sets of of points these purple ones
and these orange ones
if we want to estimate the mean of these
points
we could estimate them as totally
separate as
unpooled parameters where we just
well we take the purple points get their
mean and we take the orange points and
get their mean
um but you probably see that the orange
one has
more points than the purple one so
you're a bit more certain about this
value than this one
you can also take them fully together
put them in one single group
and then you get a pooled estimate and
you say oh i'm pretty sure
the mean of these points is somewhere in
between them
but that's also not great right we do
want to be able to say that our
that our products are different they
don't have to be exactly the same
but they're not completely different
either
so what do you have in between oh
partial pulled
and partial pooling basically says i'm
going to
take my original measurements and i'm
going to sort of shrink the parameter
estimates
towards the global mean in this case or
what i would have estimated
if i would have estimated them all
together so
we're allowed to deviate from it and the
extent to which we deviate from it
is determined by the amount of evidence
that we have that day
that they deviate from it so because we
have less evidence that the purple
points
deviate from pulp because there's just
less observations
we see that the partial pooled estimate
is much closer to
our fully pulled estimate whereas for
the orange points we have a bunch of
more data points
so our partial pool estimate is still
very close to our unpooled estimate
and this concept is called shrinkage
because it basically shrinks
shrinks our estimates towards the global
mean towards our pool estimate um
i'm actually in the interest of time
going to skip through these two slides
please show you i'm also not going to
build it i'm going to just directly show
you how the code then
goes and looks so i modified
this case and you see that the one
parameter that we're trying to estimate
is this beta
and if the pool type is not partial
pooling then we see that the definition
is basically the same as what we had and
it's a normally distributed variable
of a shape and groups and params and
params is the
order or twice the order and
that basically means that
um if there is uh if there's complete
pulling and groups will be set to one
and if there's uh completely non-pooled
then n groups is set to the amount of
groups that we have
the interesting part though happens in
this partial pulling so we still have
this data variable
but it's now a deterministic variable
and it's actually
the mu beta plus the offset beta times
the sigma data
and these mu beta and the sigma beta are
globally estimated parameters and these
are these two
and we see that they only have a shape
for the number of components that we
have
not a shape for the amount of groups
that we have
so these are globally estimated for all
our series
the only thing that we have separate for
each series
is this offset data it's n groups by m
perhaps
so offset beta basically estimates how
far away
from the global mean in terms of the
amount of standard deviations that it
has
is each individual time series beta
vector
and that is that partial pooling
and we see basically exactly the same
with our linear
trend we needed to estimate this k and
we needed to estimate the delta
so the initial growth and the the growth
changes
i basically decided to make the m always
oh that actually should be dedented here
the m is uh
is never shared i thought that didn't
really make sense for an intercept
um but we once again have a sigma and an
offset we don't have a mean here because
i i kind of assumed that the mean would
always be zero it's like
how far away is it from zero for each
group
and basically that allows us to write
our final model for our data down like
this so our partial pulled model
is a linear trend with 10 change points
plus
a constant between -1 and 1
times the yearly seasonality which is
partial pooled
so we don't have a single seasonality
but they will be drawn together a bit
and then there is this indicator this
constant thing
that's basically just a value between
minus one and one
to say to say is this a co-season or a
contra seasonal product
we then take a weekly seasonality that's
this thing
and we add it to it in the end and we
call fit
to actually go and fit the entire thing
and then our result looks like this and
when we start comparing it to
our unfold estimate we see that
especially
for the observations for the for the
series where we didn't have a lot of
data
um so the gray one a bit but in much
bigger effect
the green and the yellow one we just get
much more sensible
predictions because we basically say
please treat them as if they have some
kind of parameters
shared with the rest of our series for
which we do have a lot of data
if we look at the individual components
we see everything also makes a lot of
sense here
the trend is very much the same as that
it was but our seasonality
is basically completely agreed upon
and that is because this this scaling
allows us
to to deviate nicely from it and you
might even go a step further here and
say well
the seasonality should maybe just be
fully pulled at this point
might even be better for a seasonal
or the weekly seasonality sorry also
seems to be
a bit tighter um we obviously see that
they're not the same
there's different skills effects but the
overall pattern of like day two being
more
positive and day five being very
negative and day four
seems to hold in all the different
series
um that's also how because that's how we
construct the model where we say
please shrink them together we think all
the weekly seasonalities
should be relatively similar
right so all of this is open source it's
all my github
github.com time series
uh but it's not really ready for like
prime time production usage yet
um the fitting process works well
uh but something that's still like very
much in flux is the predictions api
um the way it currently works is just
not sufficient
uh it's very hard to add well it's very
easy to add additional regressors like
the events and like
promotions and stuff but it's very hard
to get them in the predictions api at
the moment
so i need to basically redo part of that
um
and and when that's done i think i think
the core is mostly there and i'm going
to push it to pipe ui
and hope people will uh will start using
it
and then we can add basically whatever
we need at that point right if we need
other seasonality functions
like radial basis functions well we can
if we need the saturating growth that
profit describes
we can if we want to add like mini
gaussian processes for
holiday effects sure why not
um and and that's sort of what my entire
goal is with this
to build almost like a domain specific
language
that makes it very easy to basically
plug and play
with different blocks for time series
only
i hope you enjoyed it and i'll gladly
take any questions if they are there
thank you this was super helpful and
definitely interesting
um we have a question uh are these
results for each case
uh for the case when we are creating a
model for the each time series
right so the bottom one here
um is in
indeed a completely separate models for
each individual time series
so this is the completely unpulled
example the bottom
chart here and the top chart here is
with this partial pooling
so i estimate them all together um
i allowed parents to deviate but i do
estimate them all together
another question is how does your model
work with
other time series datasets right um
so define what other time series data
sets means because that's a very broad
topic
are you going to predict stock market
prices with this no
not at all there's no seasonality in
there and in general predicting stock
markets
is isn't a bad idea so that's not what
i'm focusing on anyway
brain waves um same thing that's also
time series
but i don't think there's a lot of
seasonality in brainwaves so
probably i wouldn't do this for for that
kind of data either
um i've been sort of toying around in my
spare time with with another data set
with wikipedia page views
um and that does seem to work quite well
right because wikipedia page views also
have this
um this sort of shared behavior right if
there's a
if there's a football club playing uh
like there's there's football season so
naturally
different football clubs will have more
traffic to their pages in football
season for example
um there's this these holiday effects
where
people will look for wikipedia pages for
touristic
destinations in summer and in winter
those will be different so you'll have
those
call and contrast seasonal effects and
that does seem to work
um reasonably well as well
the effect is a bit less pronounced as
with this one and the fitting here is
quite a bit easier so i went with this
example for
for the talk but um it does work for
those kinds of data sets
yeah okay great um
another question is how to check the
performance with this type of model
maybe evaluation metrics or
information criteria um i think that's
the same as with
all other time series models um
i personally like just out of sample
predictions so
doing rolling forward rolling window
moving forward cross validation either
in a nested way or not
that does seem to work well for my use
cases most of the time
but if you're currently used to using
aic or bic or some
something else for your for your model
um evaluation that should work fine for
this as well
yeah um another question is can we add
oxagen's information that follows the
hierarchical structure of the data for
example dynamic
prices for different for different
products
one with where we would like to have a
global
parameter for price but still adopt the
individual price for each product
um if i understand you correctly i think
we should be able to do that because
this this um
right this constant thing i still need
to add a component that says
and you still need to add a regressor um
that's in the works but
part of that is the problem with the
prediction api that i mentioned
but i basically have a regressor
component in the works that says
regress on a specific column
and that's also possible to estimate
that hierarchically
so i think the answer to your question
is yes if i understand it correctly
and if not let me know
or maybe reports you can't ask can you
answer this question
um okay there is another question from
uh
from me personally um did the length of
the data sets
have to be the same or maybe this model
can handle any time serious length
sorry the question was does the length
of the data sets have to be the same
uh yeah um no they don't
uh they they um like so i chose
yeah i didn't even need to do that so
when we go back to our original data
we we actually see that the length of
the individual series is already
different
for some reason loading the gif is
really hard
right
go back too far right so
the length of the individual time series
is already different but it would have
also just worked if orange and green or
yellow and green
have started here right there's there's
no issue there
um there is this thing so the trend
currently i estimated separately i
basically said well
all individual series are allowed to
have their own trend
um so as long as the seasonality is sort
of on the same scales for the product
then it's fine if they are completely
different lengths or completely
different
time frames there's no worry there yeah
okay thank you how would you deal with
the seasonality in the
various um of the day yeah it's a good
question um
so in terms of the model it's actually
not that hard because
what i did now was just say there isn't
there is some kind of variance that's
constant that was this error term that i
estimated
and it wouldn't be very hard to make
this
dependent on time in any way right we
could say that that the errors actually
follows the same fourier seasonality
and increase indeed at certain points
and decrease at other points
the main thing that i was struggling
with is
is where to put this in the api at this
point
um so
you could probably like you can't just
add it as a component right because
that's that's not what that noise is you
can't really estimate it in that sense
um so i would need some kind of marker
or maybe some kind of other
operator to actually say well if i if i
do like a bar
maybe like a bit wise or that that sort
of
indicates that that is how the variants
should be estimated
but i wasn't really too pleased with
with how that looked yet
so conceptually definitely possible but
still would need to be built and if you
have any suggestions on on
how an api could look for that i'm i'm
super open to suggestions
because that's indeed a very uh would be
a very nice addition to this
to this to this library
okay great so we definitely want to give
a huge thank you to matthias
this was awesome and super helpful uh
thank you
please uh please follow us on twitter
for details about the upcoming talks
uh to get notified and with that again
thank you matthias
and thanks to everyone for joining yeah
uh thanks for for hosting the for
hosting this event
um best of luck with all the additional
webinars coming up
and um yeah if anyone wants to get in
touch i'm
always available on like linkedin or
twitter and i'm happy to
uh to engage with you on this because
i i enjoyed this library i enjoy working
on it and
if anyone has suggestion uh please
please come ahead yeah nice thank you so
much
oh great thank you thank you and uh
hopefully see you next time or at pi
data global
yeah sure of course thank you bye-bye